JAMES MULCAHY: Do you want to do
some deep thoughts to start out
or--
ANDREW ZIMMERN: I'm hot toast.
I'm higher than most.
I'm not from France,
but I love French toast.
I'm the chief of relief,
contain the wild beast,
the finesse of the West,
the masterpiece of the East.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: If this TV
thing doesn't work out.
JAMES MULCAHY:
Yeah, that was not
planned ladies and gentlemen.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: I
shamed-- I would
love to say I just
through of it now,
but I shamed Alain
Ducasse with that
three weeks ago at
an event that he
was being a complete and total
disappointment for-- seeing
your heroes just jerks
is just one of the worst
things in the world to see.
The emperor has
no clothes, right?
I mean, it's awful.
I'm sure all of you Denny
Hastert fans feel the same way.
I mean, it was awful.
I was at an event and Ducasse
was less than participatory,
even though he'd agreed to do
certain things at the event.
And so as the quasi-MC
friend of the hosts
kind of guy with
the microphone, I
decided the only way to get back
at him would be to rap at him,
and then ask him if
he was uncomfortable.
He was.
It was a personal
career highlight for me.
Anyway, I digress.
JAMES MULCAHY:
No, this is great.
We've never opened with
a good rap battle story.
It's one of the best
ways of solving problems.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: It's an anarchy.
I'm an anarchist.
In life, we are making bread.
I am yeast.
I mean, this is not
a fucking salad.
I mean, we're making bread.
JAMES MULCAHY: In
that kind of spirit,
let's do introductions quickly.
Yeast, anarchist, chef,
blogger, television personality,
James Beard Award
winner, everyone
knows who this guy
is, Andrew Zimmern.
He is here today to
talk to us about--
[APPLAUSE]
--he just went to
the [INAUDIBLE].
And when I asked him-- by
the way, I'm James Mulcahy.
I'm the executive
producer of Zagat video.
Watch us on youtube.com/zagat.
So we were chatting about what
we wanted to talk about today.
And Andrew said he wants to talk
about the broken food system
and how to fix it.
I assume it's going to
take more than a rap
battle to fix that one.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: You know,
we've tried everything else
and it hasn't
worked, so why not?
Why not?
Hamburger Helper just
did a hip hop album
as a promotional activation.
I don't know, anyone here seen
or heard the Hamburger Helper--
one person did.
I mean, it is marketing magic.
Their sales of Hamburger
Helper went up 27%.
More people, in the first week,
touched that activation then
saw all of their ads
aggregated in the United States
over the course of a year.
It was the most successful
thing that General Mills
has done in the marketing space
in years-- years and years.
And like all big
corporations, I'm
crossing my fingers that they
will do it again and learn
from that.
So I don't think it's that.
It may not be that far off
to say maybe a rap battle
isn't such a bad idea with that.
You know, giant
corporations-- I love
saying these kinds of things.
I've just realized I'm sitting
in a giant corporation.
Giant corporations get
really, really risk averse.
And it becomes really
tough territory for them.
Has anybody--
there's a TV newcomer
named Anthony Bourdain.
Anybody hear of him?
[LAUGHTER]
My first season at Travel
Channel and his second season,
the network aired
a special episode
where I did a half
hour alone of my show,
then Tony was in the second
half hour of the show.
Then I was in the first
half hour of his show.
Then he did a half hour alone
to conclude his show's hour.
So it was like a real
crossover, but I guess, well,
two hour-- anyway, you
get the idea, right?
And at the time, it was
the highest rated thing
Travel Channel had
ever done other
than like one weird episode
of "World's Best Beaches"
and some fluke on
the poker tour show
during a political State of
the Union speech or something.
By the way, Travel Channel
ratings go through the roof
whenever there is like
a presidential speech
and everyone wants to go
to lifestyle that night.
And they never did it again.
And I ask every single year,
not just with me and Tony,
but why not this talent
and that-- and the fans
love that kind of stuff.
So you can never overestimate
or underestimate-- I'm not sure
which it is-- the power
of a giant corporation
to make the wrong decision.
Let's get back on topic.
JAMES MULCAHY: So kind
of a broad stroke first,
this broken food system that
you want to talk about today.
My question is, how broken
is it and how bad is it?
What point are we at right now?
ANDREW ZIMMERN:
It's really broken.
It's really bad.
And we're at a-- I think
we're at a momentous time
where we can slide into the
abyss and be done with it.
And I'm talking about good
food for all as we know.
Let's just call
it-- drop labels.
I hate the organic, natural.
I mean, all those
names have been
co-opted and branded
and mislegislated.
You can call something
organic on a shelf,
but you're allowed to spray
it with every pesticide known
to man before the plant
flowers or blooms, which
is the beginning of the
fruit or vegetable growth.
I don't know how many
botanists are in the room,
but this is the most
ridiculous law of all time.
I mean, all these chemicals
go into our water system.
They damage our fields.
It hurts crop rotations,
a lot of fallout
from these kinds of issues.
But there it is, you can
still call it organic.
You can call something
organic or natural
on the shelves if it's, what,
89% or 93% natural organic,
only a certain number of
the ingredients in there.
And I'm misstating it maybe
by a percentage point or two.
But that's not important.
The idea is that the
words are meaningless.
We all know what a real
food system looks like,
which is abundant food that's
healthy and good for us
available for all.
I mean it's just kind
of a simple concept.
But I believe--
Let me just define
a couple terms.
I believe we are midway in a 25,
30 year social change movement
sufficient to recover
from the damage
that we've done
to our food system
over the last 50, 60 years.
Social change movement took
25, 30 years for seat belt
legislation appropriate
so that now my child, when
I get into the car--
I literally have
to strap in before I
actually get in the car.
Because, Dad, your seat belt.
But that's the coolest thing
in the whole world.
Smoking cigarettes was really
cool when I was my son's age.
It's not really cool now.
And there's warning
labels on the boxes.
Stronger warning labels, by the
way, in Europe than over here.
I don't know how many of
you buy cigarettes overseas,
but there's this giant white
label with black writing
that says, this package may
kill you or will kill you.
I mean, it's amazing.
But it took 25, 30 years for
us to destroy the Marlboro Man.
We're in the middle of this
social change movement.
We can continue to pursue
policies, lifestyles.
And all of us turn a
blind eye to the fact
that eating well, as
we defined it earlier,
is a class issue in America.
We can ignore that fact, or we
can do something to change it.
It used to be an embarrassment
in the late '70s, early '80s
when I came into the food
scene as a young cook,
fresh off the boat
from Europe and Asia
where I'd been staging, trying
to put together a college
career, trying to figure out
where I belonged in the food
system as a professional.
But it was odd then
that really good food
was being served in
restaurants for a lot of money.
And so many people that I knew
couldn't afford to eat in them.
And it's only
gotten worse, right?
Increasingly, our-- and I'm
very pro restaurant by the way.
I just believe that
we have to have access
to food in abundant
supply that's healthy.
And we're actually--
our government
is pursuing policies that are
the complete opposite of it, so
much so that as my friend Tom
Colicchio often reminds people,
if you are paranoid
or enough of a cynic,
you might think that the
government is actually
anti-social justice movement.
I believe there's so much
confusion on this subject
that we've gotten away from the
nuts and bolts, common sense
sort of way of
doing things that we
were doing a hundred years ago.
I mean, we've centralized
our food system.
And everyone realizes it's a
mistake to have 8, 9, 10, 12--
pick whatever stat you like--
companies making 60%, 70%,
80%-- pick whatever percentage.
And it's different
every year, right?
It differs on what
magazine article you read.
But the point is to
concentrate so much power
in the hands of so few
when it comes to food
is a real problem, right?
We have subsidized corn in this
country, famously-- I mean,
I don't need to educate you
guys on that-- to the point
where that food is
practically free.
And we wonder why
people on food stamps
are buying so much of the
stuff that is so bad for them.
Why is it more expensive to
buy a fresh peach in America
in 2016 than to buy a fast
food fried chicken sandwich?
I saw an ad last night.
I was watching the hockey
game in my hotel room.
And on came an ad
for Burger King.
10 Nuggets now cost--
AUDIENCE: $1.50.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: It's $1.49
actually, but very good.
And I was like, what
brilliant marketing
person over there at
Burger King's ad agency
said, no, no, no.
Don't make it $1.50.
Make it $1.49, because you
know that it costed out--
someone on the food
side was like, oh shit,
we can do that for $1.50 as long
as we get them to buy the giant
Coca-Cola.
And you know, when you're
making lunch or dinner
for a family that doesn't have
a lot or a person that doesn't
have a lot, so unhealthy.
That fried-- and by the
way, that $1.49 chicken
is not fresh, nice chicken meat
raised by Farmer Jones upstate
in a chicken farm that
if you closed your eyes
and imagined a chicken farm,
that's what it looks like.
Does not look like that.
It comes from a
horrible place where
this stuff gets slurried in
famous Jamie Oliver style,
right?
Are you aware-- you saw
the Jamie Oliver thing
where he took all the bones and
the crap that was half rotten
and pureed it, and then
they ammoniated it.
And then the machines
take the ammonia out
and you're left with
this pink slurry
of chicken bone and fat and
skin that most nuggets are
made from?
Yes, no?
I'm getting nodding heads.
So in a world-- in a world-- I
mean, this is America in 2016.
I love my country so much.
I am the biggest
patriot that I know.
I mean, I'm really overboard.
I'm like Abraham Lincoln,
Washington cherry tree,
you know, sons of liberty,
love this country.
How is it in the
greatest country
in the history of the world,
in the greatest civilization,
at a point in time where we have
the most romantic and loving
relationship with food,
where we know the most,
can produce the most, and
have the technical ability
to feed the most, are 20%
of Americans food insecure?
I just don't get it.
It's no longer an embarrassment.
To me, that's criminal.
It's criminal.
I don't understand why
it's illegal for someone
to sell loose joints-- those are
marijuana cigarettes-- in grade
schools, but it's OK to
give them soft drinks that
have 40 grams of sugar in them.
Oh wait, sorry, soft
drinks only have 28 to 30.
It's the mock mango
smoothies from Odwalla
that have 40 to 60
grams of sugar in them.
So if a kid drinks
one of those, I
mean-- I don't know about
how many of you are parents,
but at the time that my
8-year-old was drinking them,
it was like, I mean peel
him off the ceiling.
He's done.
I mean, it's a three hours
shutdown at that point.
I can not understand for the
life of me how in this country
we let that kind of thing go on.
And we could go
on and on and on.
I mean, diabetes is-- type
two diabetes is up like crazy.
Our waistlines are growing.
And the sensible solutions
are out there for people.
But somehow they're
either not cool enough
or our legislators don't
take them seriously.
There's a giant problem.
So we're at this
shapeshifting point
where we can continue
to ignore the problem,
and things will get
worse-- irrevocably worse
in terms of, we're
losing species, right?
Giant bluefin tuna
stocks, they have now--
I just read it two
or three days ago.
And for years we've been
hearing giant bluefin
tuna are disappearing.
Giant bluefin tuna
are disappearing.
And everyone would say
well, slow down a second.
Underwater schools of
fish-- and everyone,
fish experts were taking
about pelagic fish,
pelagic fish are
fairly reliable.
And they're like oh, cod
stocks and other things,
they come and go, and
how if it has off years,
and it comes and goes.
And tuna experts were
saying not pelagic fish--
not pelagic fish.
And sure enough, they
now have determined
that tuna is down 98%
over the last 50 years
and almost been fished
into extinction.
On the flip side, fruits-- we
were talking earlier, bananas.
I don't know how many of you
read the banana.com blog.
One of my favorites.
I used to tell these
stories because I was
aware of the issue in the '60s.
But in the '50s, there was
a great-- for a hundred
years, 1850 to 1950, there
was an incredible banana
being shipped all over the
world out of South America.
There was a blight.
And that species was killed.
And they found a blight
resistant cultivar
banana called the Cavendish.
And that's the banana that we've
eaten, I believe, since 1962.
99% of the bananas in the
world that are eaten-- sorry,
in the West are
Cavendish bananas.
Well now there's a
Cavendish banana blight,
one that's so bad that the
global banana conference was
moved from its location
in Costa Rica this year
to Miami because they didn't
want people being exposed
to bad bananas or
some people trying
to smuggle other species.
Apparently a lot of shenanigans
go on at banana conferences.
No jokes, please.
And they moved it to Miami.
And they are
basically saying, we
are going to have a new banana.
And the new bananas
that they're looking at,
the two or three that they
can cultivate easily and swap
into these farmers and get the
numbers going-- in other words,
the trees will grow fast
enough to produce fruit.
And we won't skip
years where we just
don't have enough bananas-- are
ones that are-- wait for it--
easier to transport,
thicker skin,
not as tasty or as good
for you, by the way.
But they'll look really
nice, and we can sell them.
It's like we're repeating the
horrific nature of the Red
Delicious apple in
our American addiction
to have something that
looks pretty and is
at the right price,
and we're going
to ignore everything else.
Which is what we do
famously with meats.
The problem with
beef in America is
that prices have
stayed steady, pegged
to inflation, since the 1950s.
And the lobbies are
very, very strong.
So the eye, the
size of the muscle,
has stayed the same
in the supermarket
in individually wrapped
portions for 45 years.
And the color has stayed
the same for 45 years,
because everyone
knows that that's
how most Americans look at it.
I want to see the
size of that muscle,
and I want to see it be
a certain color, right?
When the fact of the matter is
that everyone will tell you--
Michael Pollan has been
telling, and a lot people
have been talking
about it for 20 years.
Eat less meat, right?
More beans and
legumes, fresh fruits,
meat the size of a hockey puck,
only one or two meals a day,
on and on and on.
Brand new study just came
out a couple of days ago.
I saved all these things.
I brought my iPad because
I was going to cite.
I was doing to do
a lot of citing.
Which I always wanted
speak somewhere
where I had to do
a lot of citing.
But you can look it up.
You can Google it.
That's what I did.
A brand new study just came out
three days ago over in Europe
that confirmed in
fact that eating
less meat, in every possible
way it was measured,
is better for you.
Not eat no meat, just
way less meat, right?
So America, we are addicted
to 14 ounces, a giant steak,
or a half chicken on a
plate, big hunk of broccoli
or cauliflower, baked
potato, salad bar.
I mean, that's what we want
our plates to look like.
And that is the
least healthy way.
We all think breakfast should
look like Denny's-- two
pancakes, two eggs,
bacon, sausage,
cup of-- it's much
better to have a French
hooker's breakfast, cup of
espresso and a cigarette.
I mean, it's actually
better for you
than the American
classic breakfast.
So I mean, we are at
this place in time
where we've done so
much, so much damage.
I mean, we can go
on and on for hours
talking about chicken farms
and feedlots and water supply
and all this kind of stuff.
We need to have a major,
comprehensive national food
policy, and one agency
that is in charge
of the legislation-- of
supporting the legislation that
comes out of the creation
of that department.
And that's really the nuts
and bolts solution of it.
I mean, you can peck
away at this thing,
but I think our big
problem over the years
has been we do galas to
raise money for food shelves
where it doesn't make a dent
in feeding the populations that
need the food.
I'm on the board of
several agencies.
taste for the NFL.
I mean, we raise millions
of dollars every year.
We support these food shelves
in all the NFL cities.
And every year when I talk
to people who run the food
shelves, we cannot keep up with
the number of people who need.
And the people who
are there are not
homeless people who somehow
have found themselves
without a refrigerator.
We're talking about,
in some cases, families
where both parents work.
It used to be the
classic one income
families couldn't support.
Now we're finding even--
because of the minimum wage
issue and stuff like that-- that
some dual income families can't
afford to feed themselves
21 meals a week for their--
and have the car they need
to drive, a safe home.
I mean, this is America in 2016.
Something is radically,
radically wrong.
We are throwing so much love and
attention at the wrong places.
The government is slashing--
I think the last farm bill,
they were cutting
$9 or $10 billion--
that's with a B-- out of
the food stamp program,
something that has been on
of the few things that been
working for a long time, right?
And we finally got SNAP and
other types of food assistance
programs to have their chits
accepted at farmers markets
and places like that so it
can actually be somewhat
of a sustainable system.
And we can't raise
that kind of money
doing galas and telethons and
donations and Salvation Army
type stuff.
I mean, it's just we
can't keep up with it.
FDA and USDA, they
overlap on some things.
They don't meet on others.
And there's a huge
place in the middle
that we're just not
taking care of people
and they're falling through to
the-- there is no safety net.
We need to radically
change how we look at food.
And I believe, as do
a bunch of others,
that the solution has to be
political and legislative.
And that's I think where
all the new thinking
of some national
leaders on this,
thought leaders on this issue
is that it has to be political.
Tom Colicchio and his
FPA, FoodPolicyAction.org,
have started four
or five years ago,
created themselves, and
started going down that road.
And I do believe that is
the only solution that's
going to work.
JAMES MULCAHY: How
far away do you
think we are from kind of an
overarching solution like that.
You're describing
global problems as well,
so it really doesn't just
rest with our country.
And then it's the
local governments
and local progressive
places maybe feeling
exploitable a little
bit with these policies?
ANDREW ZIMMERN: Well
the problem is that none
of the policies match.
And they don't queue up dollar
wise in terms of matching funds
from the government,
which is why
we need a national,
a United States
government, a federal
agency to man this thing.
Once we get a federal agency
online that's actually
doing the job that government
is there for, I am-- complete
transparency, I am a left
wing, 1960s Lindsay liberal.
He was mayor of this city for
eight years when I was born.
That was the environment
I grew up in.
I'm not on Karl
Marx's left knee,
but I'm on his
right knee I mean,
I'm almost all
the way at the end
of the-- I'm not quite
a social utopian,
but there are things about it.
So I will confess, I'm at
the far end of the spectrum,
just so you know
where I'm coming from.
However, I really
do believe there we
are at the time and place
where the problems have been
so easily isolated that
while as left wing as I am,
I don't believe in
bigger government
because bigger government
tends to cloud the issues.
I believe in the
power of business.
I teach entrepreneurship
at Babson College.
I believe that business,
especially small business,
can save the food world.
And I've dedicated the last
four or five years of my life
towards trying to enable and
teach and help people grow
those small food companies
all across the country
for that reason, because I've
seen so many of them fail.
And I believe that you've
got to pick a place to do it.
And if I believe in
decentralizing our food system,
I'd be working positively
towards a changed--
an end, a means to do that.
But at its very core, our
founding fathers, I do believe,
felt that the one place that
governments had a major role
was in protecting the safety
and security of its people.
And I believe that includes
health and wellness.
And I believe that it
has risen to that level.
And we have two antique
departments, the FDA
and the USDA, that
should be scrapped.
A new one should be built. We
should have a food department.
There should be a
national food policy.
I find it curious
that no one has even
asked-- I have not
heard, and I've
been listening really closely.
No one has asked
any candidate what
their position is on National
School Lunch Program.
I mean, that's pretty important.
Last time I checked,
everybody in this room
was a kid once
who ate at school.
Some private, some public,
but everyone ate at school.
I mean, shouldn't we
have some kind of way
to make sure that our children
are eating the right thing,
at the very least?
Everywhere that the public
dollar intersects with food
we have a problem--
jails and institutions,
the way we feed and care
for our elderly in assisted
living facilities that receive
government money for food.
Those populations are
the worst served by food.
And I'll tell you
something that I
think we all have a little
bit of a trouble with.
I am part of the problem,
because I globe trot
around the world, and have the
last 11 years, showing-- yes, I
show both sides of the coin.
I'm tribal.
I'm in very poor neighborhoods.
I'm in slums.
Largest slums in the world,
I've done entire programs from.
But I've also done the million
dollar Victorian mansion
in Mississippi and the
fabulous big spread
and it looks like it should
be out of the centerfold
of "Garden and Gun."
And it's a lifestyle that only
a handful of people can access.
And I feel a little bit
of guilt about that,
because I'm selling something
that nobody can participate in.
And I think we have
to start-- we're
so badly misaligned
that where it starts
is with some kind
of national policy.
And then it could
go down to state
and local, because
there are certain things
that state and local governments
are ideally suited to monitor,
put in place-- the needs
are different in Alaska
than they are in Florida.
I'm the first one to tell you.
But I mean, the idea
that we have thousands
of tons of meats rotting away
in freezers, whether it's
alligator meat in Florida or
bison meat in the Southwest,
and we can't get
that healthy protein
into the hands of people that
need it the most-- I mean,
we talked about-- I talked
about the magazine article.
And you hear people
all the time talking--
you probably recognize
this phrase-- the warm hug
that food gives.
It does.
It makes some people
feel really good.
And if one of you
came to my house
and I cooked a really
wonderful home cooked meal
for eight of you and we
sat on the deck outside
and watched the sun
set and the moon rise,
it would be an
idyllic experience
and you'd get that
warm hug that food
gives, because the food
would be really good
and it would be a
really nice setting.
But the people who need
that aren't you guys.
The people who need that warm
hug are seniors in those state
run facilities, people in
jails and institutions,
kids in school.
Right, you follow me?
We're giving that warm hug
to the wrong population.
JAMES MULCAHY: So in
that kind of spirit,
is there somewhat that
we can do as consumers,
as more average consumers,
not these needy populations,
make better choices about
one form of food system?
And the consumer dollar talks
as well in addition to policy.
Does that help, or is too late
for that sort of intervention?
What are some of
the better choices
we can make in our every
day decision making?
ANDREW ZIMMERN: You hit
the nail on the head.
Take the question mark out of
that and make it a statement,
and that is your answer.
I firmly believe it's why
I make the show I make.
And I've said in a
lot of interviews,
you can change the food
world one plate at a time.
You make it every time
you go to your market.
You make it every time you
sit down with friends to eat.
I am a lotus eater.
I am a hedonist.
I am still going to
drink-- I understand
that sugary sweet sodas
are bad, and I still,
once a week, I
love my root beer.
Sometimes I'll have two.
I love root beer.
Root beer is like, [SIGHS], and
it's the elixir of the gods.
But I know it's not good
for me so I have to limit
my intake of root beer.
And I talk about these
issues with my friends.
And I actually-- I'm looking
out at a sea of-- well,
there's one or two of you
that are younger than me.
But I'm looking out
at a sea of faces
that I believe, because I'm
an optimist, a super optimist,
I believe that you
people actually
care more about this issue
at this time in your lives
than my generation did at
that time in our lives.
I think that you guys have
been preached at and TVed at
and magazine articled
at and online
blogged at about these
issues to know that there
is something wrong with this.
My parents never wanted to
have me volunteer somewhere
to do something,
but my wife and I
want our kid to volunteer and
do things and help other people.
I think the social climate is
different in America in 2016,
in a good way.
And I think that if you
just look at it in-- I
hate these terms, so I
don't want you to think
that I support the use of them.
Things like farm to table--
it's just a God awful term.
Whoever names the generations,
who's in charge of that?
Who named millennials
millennials?
I don't get it.
However, everybody has
sign posted the five or six
attributes that
millennials represent.
And my favorite one
is transparency.
And I've tested and measured
this with millennial friends
of mine and millennials
who work for me
at my office in Minnesota.
And they are a much
different feeling--
they have a much different
feelings about this issue
than I ever had.
So I do believe that voting
with our pocket books,
practicing what we preach,
spreading the gospel,
but most importantly,
becoming politically
motivated to help change this.
And I think that's something
that our country has
done a really bad job of.
Famously in a lot
of countries that
are stable or semistable
democracies now,
the first year that they held
elections, turnout was massive.
And I'm not trying to hold
up Iraqi politics as a model
for the American system.
But I remember watching TV
after the first Gulf War.
And one of the beautiful
stories that came out
of that incredible
shithole of an event
was seeing so many
real Iraqi citizens,
I mean moms, dad and people--
and I've spent time in Iraq.
I've spent time in Syria.
It's the most beautiful
and nicest, kindest people
in the world.
My Syria show is must
see TV for anyone
who wants to witness what the
kindest society in the world
looked like just a few
short years ago, albeit
ruled by the wrong people.
The folks who actually live in
that country, the most gracious
and kind I've ever met.
Incredible show we shot there.
But seeing Iraqis with
the purple finger--
I have an Iraqi ballot sheet
hanging in my living room
as a reminder to me, because
I put it in the living room
and not in my office because
I wanted visitors to my home,
when they're sitting,
they have to look at that
and they have to look at a
stuffed Buffalo on the wall
that I shot.
And it's purposeful
so I can talk
to people about these issues
that are very important to me.
And they had, I don't
know, 90% turnout.
I mean, they couldn't keep
them away from the polls.
Here in our country, we
have political entities,
politicians, local and state
governments that are actually
trying to prevent
certain population
groups from voting,
or at the very least
make it harder for them
to vote, in a country that
was founded on the
premise that everyone
should have a right to vote.
I mean, it was over a tax
issue, but I mean, taxation
without representation, right?
I mean, you get a right
to vote in America.
And our turnout is notoriously
low, election after election.
I believe that if we push
our legislators-- that's why
I like Tom Colicchio's group.
They do that
legislator scorecard.
And it's all based
on food issues.
If we push our food
leaders or if we
push our political leaders
onto what a lot of us
call kitchen table
issues and we insist
on holding their
feet to the fire,
we will do more to help
change our country.
You know, I am not the one
who coined this phrase.
And I'm not even sure Tom did.
I'm sure it was
smarter people than us.
But the moment we actually
have a food policy and one
legislator loses
their job because we
don't like the way
they dealt with it,
you will see a giant sea change.
And I believe that will happen
within the next 10 or 12 years.
I think we have to
reformulate our cabinet.
I think there has to be
a national food policy,
and that needs to be enforced
by a food department, not
an FDA or USDA.
And I really believe that we
can start at the local level
to do that too, get our
local politicians talking
about food first.
I mean, local congressmen,
city council members,
local-- when I say
local legislatures,
I mean at the state level.
You know, they need
to be invested.
Farms, those are jobs program.
And I look at companies.
Google's a different
kind of company.
But I look at the fastest
growing food company
in the world right
now is a company
called Hampton Creek,
run by my friend
Josh Tetrick out of San
Francisco, California.
His first product
was a vegan egg.
But he didn't sell it.
His second product
was mayonnaise
made with the vegan egg.
So it emulsified with oil.
And it tasted fantastic.
It's a great tasting mayonnaise.
Now what he used to create
that egg were plant products.
Proteins and other chemicals
extracted from certain plants
were used to make a fluid
that would replicate the 22
actions that an egg has
in the kitchen, right?
Crazy.
In fact, raised in the
tens of million of dollars,
put the smartest
people in a room,
and three years later they came
out with this amazing stuff.
They now have like 43
products launching by August.
They're the fastest growing
food company in the world.
They just went over a
billion dollars in sales.
It's just this epic kind
of wonderful success story.
I've known Josh for a long time.
And one of the things that I
take a little bit of credit
for it is that through
our talks and friendship
and telling the story of
Hampton Creek as many times
as I have-- and I was the
first one to profile him
on television-- it
occurred to me because I've
been to all of these
horrifically poor countries
around the world-- let's
just pick one, call it Haiti.
If he is using sweet potato
vines and certain types of peas
that grow like wildfire
in a tropical environment,
isn't it fantastic
that we could have
farms in third and
fourth world countries
in the equatorial band around
our country growing vegetables
that actually could get a
fair market price the way
we started to with coffee and
chocolate and vanilla beans,
right?
And wouldn't it be wonderful
if those applications
could be used towards
healthifying our food system?
It would be a
diplomatic victory.
It would be a jobs bill.
It would be an
economic development.
So they're just
throwing millions
of millions of dollars
at Haiti and letting
their government make decisions
about what to do with it.
If we did it through the
entrepreneurial business
system of putting food
companies in there
that were doing that, what a
fantastic, fantastic thing.
Those kind of things I
really support, and I believe
searching out those products
and buying them-- Hellmann's
famously sued Hampton
Creek because they called
their first product Just Mayo.
And Hellmann's
said, oh no, no, no.
That's not mayonnaise.
They can't call themselves Mayo.
And Josh was like, we're not
calling ourselves mayonnaise.
We're calling ourselves Mayo.
And he did it purposely so
that he could eventually
get this fight started.
And the Hellmann's
people along with,
I believe it was the FDA--
again, you can Google it.
It's a great story.
But someone made a joke about
well, we could kill him.
That would solve the problem.
And my name is
all over the thing
because I was sort of pimping
them out a lot in the media
and stuff like that.
And I was just so proud of that,
because when those people are
worried about you and
angry and making jokes
about offing the
head of this company,
you know you're on
the right track.
I mean, that's how you know
you're on the right track
when you have enemies.
My entertainment
lawyer said to me,
I'll know when I'm
really successful when
someone sues me.
I think there's
some truth to that.
So these are the
things, when you
start to scare people like that,
you're breaking the old system.
And I think Josh's
corporate motto--
it's ad hoc and kind
of behind the scenes.
It's not the official
mission statement.
But Josh's favorite
quote is, if we
could start blank over from
scratch, how would we do it?
And I think with certain
parts of our food system,
we've tried to correct it so
many times instead of saying,
you know something, bulldoze it.
Let's start over.
This is America 2016.
We have the smartest people
in the world in this country.
Let's actually reconstruct it.
It doesn't take that long.
I don't know about you guys.
I'm horrified, I
mean, horrified when
I turn on my laptop
in the morning
and my news starts just
auto populating in my inbox.
And I read-- and I
hope I get this right,
and my apologies to
Subway if I get it wrong,
but I think it was Subway.
Subway came out and said,
we have a big announcement.
We are going to use only
cage free eggs in our stores.
And I was like oh my
God, that's fantastic.
And then I kept reading down
the article and it said,
and we promise to
do this by 2025.
I mean, this is nuts.
Now I've been in the food
business a long time.
I get it.
Subway's a big company.
And so if they're going to have
a global policy with sandwiches
all of the world, the supply
lines and distributors--
so I get it if would take two
years or a year and a half.
They really want to
make sure it's right.
But there are so many suppliers
out there with cage free eggs.
And Subway, as big
a company as it is,
ain't using that many eggs.
Their egg salad isn't
their biggest seller.
But for them to come out and
say it's going to nine years
to commit to this,
to me says everything
that's wrong about our
broken food system today.
They came out with it to
make a statement because they
know people aren't going to
read more than three lines
below the thing, and
the headline everywhere
is Subway commits
to cage free eggs.
And so I was like oh
Subway, that's fantastic.
Campbell's came out
and said, we're not
going to-- we believe
in truth in labeling,
and we support the
transparency of having
no GMOs in our soups,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
What they didn't
say was what I think
they should have
said is, we're going
to make our soups from scratch.
We're going to put natural
products in our soup.
And we're going to
use the right thing.
We all know what
we're looking at.
Vegetable soup is going to
be just vegetables and soup
cooked by real people in a can.
Canned food's great.
Hamburger Helper is great.
Those things, you got to be
able to feed people, right?
We have billions of hungry
people in this world,
losing arable land, so
many different problems.
We have to have
solutions for everyone.
Not everyone is going to get
to eat Eleven Madison Park.
And you can't tell them to
build a billion seat restaurant.
I wish that was the case.
But we have to start
applying common sense stuff.
We have to start
doing it politically.
And we have to start calling
people on their bullshit.
I mean, it really has
gotten to that point.
And I think luckily
if you ask me,
I think it's going to happen
over the next 10, 12 years.
I think we're going
to see enough change.
It may take 15 to get there, but
I think we're going to do it.
JAMES MULCAHY: So
Chef, I definitely
want to leave a lot of time for
questions like we discussed.
Part of your job is to
evangelize these better ways.
And you mentioned something
to me about a blood oath
that you took with some
of your chef friends.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: I
can't talk about it.
JAMES MULCAHY: You
I want to hear about
the blood oath.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: I
absolutely-- if I told you
that story, number
one, it's that type
of thing with so many
famous people involved
and that kind of like,
who killed John Kennedy
kind of thing, where's
Jimmy Hoffa buried.
I don't-- I'll tell you.
So I'm at an after,
after, afterparty
at the Miami Food and
Wine Festival, South Beach
Food and Wine Festival.
And everybody thinks that
there's some kind of door
that the 40 or 50 food people
like me all walk through
and we're alone in
this fantastic place
and there's just vats of caviar.
And you know, satyrs
are wandering around
and Dom Perignon
Rose '62 is flowing
from machines previously
used at the Kimmelman bat
mitzvah for chocolate dipping.
And that is true.
But this was a larger party.
There were some normies there.
Horrible joke.
But it's actually very rare for
a lot of us, the right people
to be in the room
at the same time.
And there were 10 or 12 of us
gathered around a little circle
with a lot of
other people trying
to get in on the conversation.
And myself and Jose Andreas
and Colicchio and Bobby Flay
and Jean-Georges Vongerichten
and-- I'm blanking on some,
but people like that.
And we're all standing around.
And the game that we
were actually playing
was, who was cooking at
that restaurant in the '80s,
because the '80s was a decade--
I completely forget the '80s.
I'm a recovering alcoholic
and heroin addict,
and that was the decade I didn't
sober up until January of '92.
So I can't tell you a
thing about the '80s.
When I married my wife, she
laughed because I'd never
seen an episode of "Friends."
It's true.
I just missed the whole decade.
So I was cooking
a lot in New York.
And we're all
trying to figure out
who-- we were all young
line cooks coming up.
And we remember it like,
this guy was amazing.
Whatever happened to him?
He was such a better
cook than all of us.
And it's odd how so
many of us were working
in the same restaurants
at the time together
or followed each other
when one person left.
Because the world of line
cooks in New York back then
was fairly finite.
And it's amazing that so
many of us, now in our 50s,
are kind of like elder statesmen
in a much more popular food
universe.
And at one point,
someone said oh,
are you going to contribute to
such and such gala or whatever.
And Tom Colicchio
got on his soapbox.
And it was so motivating
and so inspiring to hear
somebody-- I mean,
it's one thing for me
to say it to you guys.
But when I grab my colleagues,
I mean my real peers
and colleagues by the
lapels, the ones who
aren't playing the
game the right way,
and convince them that fewer
galas, fewer fundraisers, fewer
of everything, dedicate
all your resources
to putting a million people
on the Mall in Washington, DC,
insisting that our government
change its way of doing things
and insisting on a national
food policy and a federal agency
that would supervise it.
I mean, those are
the kind of things
that are really meaningful,
and that perhaps this was
the year for all of us
to kind of, collectively,
take a step back from
pissing in the wind.
I'm still donating
as much as I can
to my local food self,
because I can't not do that.
But on the bigger,
grander scheme of things,
taking some of the energy
that I've been doing that
hasn't been making the change.
Helps to throw a
nice party, and maybe
focusing it on a couple
days on my schedule
that I go to Capitol Hill
and I work hard on something.
And it made sense to me, because
two years ago I got a phone
call from the one organization.
And they asked me to help.
They wanted me to tell
stories about Africa
and help electrify Africa.
Because if you want to make
Africa safe and secure,
how about giving
them electricity?
But let's stop throwing
money over there.
Let's stop supporting
tin pot dictators.
Let's stop supporting oligarchs.
Let's stop sending bags of
rice out of cargo planes.
Let's just give them
electricity so the food
that they grow and make
themselves can be stored.
Let's give them electricity
so that when we give them
medicines that are
perishable, they can have them
in refrigerators that work.
If you put electricity
in Namibia,
it would become one of the
leading exporters in the world
of fish and shellfish.
The best seafood in the world
comes from the Skeleton Coast
as it wraps around the Western
side of the Horn of Africa.
The best in the world
comes from there.
Not Spain, not New England,
not Australia, Namibia.
Right?
But they don't have electricity,
so they can't process the fish
and seafood.
I digress.
If we can put
together the attention
in the right way as we did with
the Electrify Africa campaign,
and if the food people took a
page out of the social justice
playbook that ONE has, solely
focusing on legislating issues
one after another
after another, I
think we would
have more success.
So it really resonated with me.
And we all sort of took
a blood oath that night
that that was going
to be our focus.
And I'm super, super proud
of that, because I've
seen it work with ONE.
So, anyway.
I said to James over lunch,
I said, I talk a lot.
So what I really want to
do is have a conversation.
So he said, we'll have 10
minutes for Q&A. I said,
let's leave 25
minutes for a Q&A.
I don't think I even
let you ask a question.
JAMES MULCAHY: I got four in.
I think I got four.
It's good.
But that said, I think
it's time for questions.
We have 10 minutes.
ANDREW ZIMMERN:
Let's do questions.
JAMES MULCAHY:
Who has a question?
We have a microphone?
Oh, the mic is over here.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: If
you shout it out,
I will repeat the question so
the me at home can hear it.
AUDIENCE: So remember when Oprah
famously said eat less meat
or don't eat meat,
and they sued her.
And that worried me because
I think that some of us
try to change things, the
food lobby's very powerful.
How do you believe that
that will get [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREW ZIMMERN: Well I think
the food lobby has gotten
smart enough as they've seen
their market share fall apart
that the way to do it is
not to threaten and bully.
The people who are calling for
not eating as much meat today
are not being sued.
We know that a
healthy diet-- I mean,
confirmed-- eat less meat.
You will live longer.
You'll be disease free.
I mean, you will
have less diseases.
You will live longer.
I mean, it is
staggering the data
in this brand new study that
just got released two days ago.
No one has sued me,
and I've been saying it
for a long time--
a year and a half.
Not because I'm a
meat eater, but just
because you want to make sure.
The last thing I want to
do is one of those people
that one year says--
a flip flopper,
and then no one believes
anything you say.
So you like to be kind
of sure of your issues
when you're a person like me
that actually has a platform.
And I take a lot
of responsibility.
I've wanted to have a platform
so I could do something
with this mic.
My show, some people think
it's fat white guy goes
around world, eats bugs.
I'm serious, that's how it's
been described, not by me,
by other people.
But there's a lot of
people-- and I'm sure,
this being a very smart
crowd, gets that it's not
about that at all.
It's about preaching patience,
tolerance, and understanding
with other parts of the world.
We're all part of
a global community.
And let's tell uniting
stories around food
rather than divisive
ones about who
you like to have sex with,
what music do we listen to,
what kind of god do we believe
in, what language do we speak,
what color is our skin.
All that shit's irrelevant.
This is 2016.
It's a very, very flat world.
Let's talk about the
things that unite us,
not the things that divide us.
And we were talking about
solutions from another place.
You know, I just
came back-- I mean,
I could list a hundred
countries right now
or a hundred cities, places I've
been in where they eat the diet
that we would best emulate.
I just came back from Okinawa.
Some of the happiest
and disease free
and the longest living people
in the world live in Okinawa.
I was cooking with five
grandmas only to find out they
were five great-grandmas,
and all in their late 80s.
And I shit you not.
If you go to my
Instagram, and you only
have to go back like
three, four weeks,
there I am with these five
ladies in the kitchen.
Not a single one of them
looks over the age of 65.
They're all in their late 80s.
And they're cooking away
and fast and conversational.
Now I just buried my
dad at age 87, 88.
Had a long, great life.
It was fantastic.
Feel happy and wanted to go.
But his condition at the end
was nothing like these women.
And the difference
there is they really
believe in Yakuzen,
the healthy attributes
of a lot of bitter
vegetables and greens
that they incorporate
in their diet.
They all still sleep on futons
and they sit on the ground
to eat, so they're constantly
up and down, up and down,
up and down.
So they're flexible.
They all exercise.
They all garden.
Because everyone, it's almost
part of the Shinto belief
in that part of Japan that
everyone, even people window
gardening, but they do it every
day so they nurture something.
And they're respected
in their culture.
Old people in our culture
are no longer cool, right?
I mean, we're even going to
put Brad Pitt and Angelina
away in a home somewhere
at some point, right?
Let's not look at them.
Ooh, they're old people.
They are in a wheelchair.
They've got diseases.
I don't want to look at that.
That could be me some day.
Out of sight, out of mind.
I mean, that's the way we
look at it in our fast paced,
disposable culture
here in America.
And I think that there
are so many people
now looking at those things
and talking about those things.
And they, by the way, eat
very small amounts of meat.
And when they do, even
when they fry their pork,
classically the style of doing
it is that it's then rinsed.
A lot of the harmful
fats come out.
A lot of the healthy
fat stay in when
pork is twice cooked like that.
So it's an amazing thing
to see and be a part of.
I think being vocal is still
important, despite that issue.
I mean, and look, who's
going to sue Oprah?
Oprah is going to come
back at him with-- I mean,
she's like her own
country, right?
She's like Switzerland.
I wouldn't want to
mess with Oprah.
JAMES MULCAHY: All
right, who else?
[INAUDIBLE], I think
in the back there.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: Great
beard by the way.
Bearded guy is next, then
we'll get to the other guy.
Bearded guy keeps pumping
his hand up and down.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: No,
no, that's all right.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
the Subway situation,
how long that would take.
My question is with
certain ingredients
that we put in a lot of
cheap foods in this country--
can you hear from
the microphone?
ANDREW ZIMMERN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
a lot of cheap ingredients
are things that are made to keep
cheap, like hydrogenated oils,
palm oils.
What do you feel is
the solution for this?
It's so widespread and it's--
to inform people about it,
it almost feels like it's
just an immediate pushback
because it's in so much.
What do you feel could
be a solution to that?
ANDREW ZIMMERN: Well I've got
some really good news for you.
Some of the largest food
companies in the world
have chosen not to go the way
of Kodak and go out of business.
So I can speak for
one in Minnesota
that I'm very, very proud of.
And it's one that is
universally vilified
as being one of the worst
examples of big food,
and that's General Mills.
General Mills had a mission
statement for the last 50 years
that really had nothing
to do with making food.
They have become
a brand company.
And a lot of their
brands used a lot
of those ingredients
and stuff like that.
New leadership team came in,
and they chose a new mission
statement.
It was announced.
But unlike those
splashy announcements
of Campbell's and
the other people,
this one kind of
went under the radar.
And they announced they had
a new mission statement.
And it was based
off a World War II
letter from the then head
of the company to the board,
the owner of the
company to the board.
I think it was James
Ford Bell the Second.
And he wrote the company, to the
board, what a wonderful thing
it was to be a part of a group
that took food and shared it
with love with the world.
And this was at a point in time
where the world had really come
together, right?
And food was needed.
And shelf stable was needed.
And big food was kind of
needed to feed people.
And there was a great
sense of pride there.
And General Mills, and
I'm going to botch it,
but essentially their
new mission statement
is to be of service of-- give
service to the world with food
through love, or
something like that.
But service, food, and love
are in their mission statement.
Food was not in
their-- the phrase food
was not in their last
mission statement.
And they are on a quest.
They're reformulating and
remaking lots of their foods.
And the reason is
that in the past,
they used to buy companies like
Annie's that made natural mac
and cheese, right, where it's
actually freeze dried cheese
and there are no
hydrogenated oils.
It's all natural product
that mimics the Kraft
mac and cheese, right?
And instead of being
$0.69, it's $1.29.
But it's still
really inexpensive
and it allows families that
want to eat healthily and give
their kids mac and
cheese, they can do it.
That's your choice.
If you want to eat
mac and cheese,
at least we have a
healthy one that isn't
filled with a lot of crap.
So General Mills
and Kraft and Nestle
and all these other
big food companies
buy companies like that.
Well now they're realizing
they can't buy them fast enough
and stay afloat, so they better
start incubating companies
like that with innovation teams,
because they have all the R&D
and all the money in the world.
So they can do it easier
than you and I could
going out to Silicon Valley
and trying to raise $10 million
and take five years just to
get in the supermarket, right?
So not only are they
putting the work
of their innovations
and R&D labs--
and General Mills
is not the only one.
All the big food companies are
doing it that I'm aware of.
And they are
committing to remake--
you know, Kraft, Nestle, all
these giant food companies have
been coming out
one after another,
because they're
afraid all of you
are going to stop
buying their product.
Because enough people
like me and Michael Pollan
are saying less meat, cook more.
Our problem and the reason
why eating well in America
is a class issue is that
sometimes we're not just cash
poor, we're also time poor.
When are we going to do it?
So it helps to
have products that
allow us to put ingredients
together in 20 minutes
and get it on the
table, or say that they
can do from the freezer
to the over to the table
in a short amount of time
and serve a family on the go.
So the good news is, is
that companies are doing it.
We're finding out
that those ingredients
aren't healthy for us.
And the new generation
of consumers,
because of their
love of transparency,
is not buying them.
So the products are changing.
I know like Progresso soups
at General Mills in August,
it's coming out they're
going to be in Tetra Paks.
It's an all natural product
cooked by real people.
I mean, it is a massive
campaign to start soup season.
And I hear about these things
because I live in Minnesota
and I have friends
of General Mills.
That's a huge, huge thing.
And as those companies
begin to do that,
it's going to catch fire,
which is why I'm bullish on it,
because those things
are not good for us.
Are we going to let this
guy be the last question?
JAMES MULCAHY:
[INAUDIBLE] time for.
That's a [INAUDIBLE]
problem as well.
ANDREW ZIMMERN: Oh my God.
JAMES MULCAHY: So
it's 2 o'clock.
Anyone who want to
roll out can do that.
We'll take one more
question and then we'll--
ANDREW ZIMMERN: Sounds great.
AUDIENCE: So I worked in the
inner city education system
here in New York City.
And I was really glad to hear
that you mention national food
programs and lunch programs.
But the thing that I noticed
and was really surprising
was that a lot of
kids, because there's
a stigma around free
lunch, won't eat it.
They'll throw it away.
I think the statistics were
50% of it gets thrown away.
How would you reach into
places like the inner city
and start to educate people and
shift the culture and stigma
around government issued food?
ANDREW ZIMMERN: So it's such
a fantastic question, and one
that I love to talk about.
I have a lot of
personal experience
with this, because as
a recovering addict
and alcoholic, the last
year of my using life, which
was 25 years ago, was
on the streets of New
York as a homeless person.
I took meals at
the Salvation Army
and soup kitchens and stuff
like that where whenever I
needed to eat or needed a bed.
And God bless you.
And the shame of
hunger insecurity
and the stigmas
around it are just
like those with addiction
and other recovery issues.
People are afraid to
come out and say it.
One of the ones we're
dealing with right
now is mental health issues.
Who wants to come out
and say, I'm bipolar.
Will I lose my job?
Will my girlfriend
want to leave me?
Will my friends talk to me?
I mean, you know, I have
mental health issues.
I'm a recovering
addict and alcoholic.
I shine up pretty good
when I'm taking my medicine
and I'm not drinking
and drugging.
You know, I'm a pretty
efficient human being.
For me, it came
down to education.
And I think one of the tent
poles of our new national food
policy has to be education.
I will tell you
right now, and this
is why I think we're in the
midst of this 30 year thing,
20 years ago I believed in the
mythology that exists today,
that if you went into a
school in the inner city
in an outer borough, which is
code for poor people of color.
I mean, it's just awful.
But if you went out
to a school like that
and you said where
does milk come from,
I do believe 20 years
ago a lot of them
would have answered
the supermarket.
I do believe that the education
that we have today, most
of those kids now
say cows, because it
became such a national joke.
Our kids don't know
where milk comes from.
So I think that the education,
especially in schools,
is growing.
I believe that your snapshot
of it is extremely accurate.
The shame associated with
asking for help is awful.
It's awful.
I've been there.
But we all know, we would
tell, if we were all-- I mean,
I'm a parent.
I tell my kid all
the time, asking
for help is a sign of strength.
It's not a sign of weakness.
And I tell him all
the time, you're
going to take steps you
don't believe in to get
results you can't imagine.
And they sound like-- those
sayings sound like greeting
cards, but they really do work.
And I think it's why we
need to have a national food
program that's
federally funded, and we
need to make it a
cabinet position
because we need to divert
education about food
to the people that need it
the most, parents and kids.
It needs to be taught as
one of our major courses.
I mean, why are we
not teaching food
when we've been doing social
studies and history and math?
I mean, look, it's
Google, right?
But take away my quadratic
equation, go for it dude.
Take away my rice
or bread, there's
revolution in the
streets, right?
I mean, we need to be studying
food and talking about it
and devoting educational
resources to it.
But I do believe
it's getting better.
And I would bet that touch
was is because we have
to let people go back to work.
JAMES MULCAHY: It is.
And I'm sorry.
It was a good moment to end on.
Everything, let's say
thank you to Chef Andrew.
[APPLAUSE]